in the Star Wars universe dead doesn't
always mean dead thanks to the series
complicated canon there are plenty of
ways that this lightning slinging
villain could have come back from the
grave or possibly escaped death entirely
here's how we know Palpatine is coming
back for episode 9
soon I'll be dead and you with me in
Star Wars just because you fell into a
seemingly bottomless pits doesn't mean
that you died Luke jumped off a platform
in Cloud City and despite the fact that
he had only one hand ended up just fine
in the legends timeline also known as
the old expanded universe Boba Fett
climbed out of the Sarlacc pit and went
on to cause even more trouble
according to samuel l.jackson even mace
windu might still be alive I'm not dead
Jedi's can fall incredibly according to
Jackson George Lucas has even co-signed
that theory heck look at what happened
with Daffy Moore at the end of The
Phantom Menace obi-wan Kenobi cut more
than half and sends him careening down a
reactor shaft somehow it didn't stick
despite missing half of his body more
rescued himself using the force got
himself a set of mechanical legs and
went on to become a major thorn in the
galaxy's side in the Clone Wars more
United the galaxy's underworld and took
over the planet Mandalore
he then went on to make an appearance
and Solo as the head of the Crimson
doncrime sent occur and he'll probably
still be kicking around in a sequel
trilogy if he hadn't challenged obi-wan
Kenobi to an ill-advised rematch in
rebels characters like Morland Boba
Fett's went on to have robust story arcs
after their on-screen deaths even if
their ends looked pretty decisive at the
time we're not even mentioning Yoda
obi-wan qui-gon Anakin and all the other
Jedi who came back as ghosts if you
don't think the Emperor is a big enough
deal to warrant that kind of second life
treatment think again you will faint
that it is you who are mistaken in
Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine finally exposes himself as a
Sith Lord and tries to sway Anakin away
from the lights he does so by making a
promise claiming that the darkside can
grant talented SIF immortality and even
bring people back from the dead as
Palpatine explains a Sith Lord known as
staff Plagueis once figured out how to
manipulate midi-chlorians using the
force unlocking the secrets of life
itself using his powers Plagueis was
able to keep his loved ones alive
supernaturally prolong his own life and
even create new living beings from
scratch like Anakin the dark side of the
force is a pathway to many abilities
some consider to be unnatural
unfortunately Plagueis made one mistake
he taught his apprentice everything he
knew once Plagueis is second-in-command
learned all of his master secrets he
killed Plagueis while the elder Seth was
sleeping becoming the new Dark Lord and
who was that apprentice
why Palpatine of course we know from
Revenge of the Sith and some Star Wars
comics that he knew all of Plagueis has
tricks including creating new life there
was since we've already seen Palpatine
use his powers to create new life and it
follows a hit up the power to cheat
death
if Palpatine used his knowledge to
escape death at the hands of his own
apprentice it wouldn't be too much of a
stretch you remember how more than Boba
Fett came back to life in the old
expanded universe Palpatine did that too
in dark empire a series published by
Dark Horse Comics in the early 90s the
Emperor returns about five years after
Return of the Jedi by transferring his
consciousness into a cloned body in fact
as Luke Skywalker comes to learn that
Palpatine created an entire stockpile of
clones that he can jump between as he
sees fit
that makes destroying Palpatine near
impossible if you kill one clone he'll
just use another one which turns out to
be enough to make a despairing Luke
submit to the dark side
when Disney bought Lucasfilm in 2012 it
wiped the slate clean the expanded
universe Palpatine's resurrection
included but the new Star Wars Canon
hasn't shied away from incorporating old
legends material when it makes sense and
of course Star Wars has already lousy
with clones meaning it wouldn't take a
lot to get audiences to buy in would it
be cool well maybe but is it possible
you better believer
an old
has been the path to immortality check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite Star Wars characters are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]